I'm gonna get to play my very favorite
game on this show with none other than
Mr DeVito this is a rapid fire behind
the scenes
[Applause]
so in one thought first thing that comes
to your mind when I list these movies
off are you ready
go for it baby Batman Returns a monkey
almost Bit Me In The Box
I'm serious I mean a big monkey a little
monkey that was supposed to deliver a
note to to me from Batman I was the
penguin I was dressed in all my regalia
you know and I was drooling and I like
this and the monkey comes down the
staircase and looks at me was terrified
and leapt at my crotch
and that was like you know very thank
God I had padding because I don't think
I had all my kids at that time oh no I
did already yeah
that's exactly what I'm looking for war
of the rosettes or the Roses was a you
know wonderful time with Michael and
Kathleen I think what stands out is uh
that I was putting them through the
paces and I'm you know doing it over and
over and over again I like to do stuff
if I have the opportunity and one one
night they were like kind of like they
wanted to talk to me you know say listen
Dan you know this is so they met me in
my dressing room and I knew this was
coming you know what I was going to get
taken down to the carpet you know what
do you call it and so I ordered like a
hell of a lot of Chinese food I mean I
ordered everything on the menu and it
came to my trailer and it was on this
table by my in my dressing room trailer
right and they came to see me so they
got and they said I sat them in the best
seat and I was standing up so I'm about
to do all this and I'm talking to them a
mile a minute like I'm doing now and I
leaned on the table and all the Chinese
food well
that was the end of the meeting I went
back to work and that was the end of
that perfect that's one way
well you
well here's another
mama from that train
thank you okay well her mom from the
train was a wonderful experience and we
had of course a brilliant Ann Ramsey
who's listening from above now or where
wherever she is and and and
um she had like some disabilities
because she survived cancer she had uh
she was a terrific woman and just every
day on the set no matter what would do
anything I wanted and I was
there's a scene in the movie where she's
hanging off the train
and in those days the way we did that
you know you will you just take somebody
and you hang them upside down
and I said to Anne is this cool should
give me that teeter-totter board right
now I'll do it and she got on a
teeter-totter board and we hung her
upside down and we had wind blowing on
her you had to do that because you know
he said long hair so the hair has to be
going in the right direction and so we
stuck her upside down and I'll never
forget the day that she did that and I
thank her for it and if you want to
watch the movie again throw a mama from
the train and Ramsey did her own stunt
in that moment
[Applause]
it well speaking of stunts and Caper and
Adventure I think you guys set the bar
with that genre of film with Romancing
the Stone yeah yeah Romancing the Stone
well I remember shooting there was a
scene in the in the movie that was uh
where I'm running away from somebody
I've got a gun in it which I I Don't Go
Near Guns by the way and but I had to do
it as a character and I'm coming down a
hill and they said you have to shoot
back at the guy but or whoever it was
that was chasing me and this is the
director telling me this so I ran down
the hill but I got up so much momentum
that I couldn't stop and I kept going
shooting over him so if you look at the
movie you see me coming down a hill with
a with a gun just
doing this you were in the moment I was
in the moment and I was also in the
moment it was gravity there was nothing
I could do I was going down the hill
like a crazy man twins ah yes we worked
out he had a big truck on the uh trailer
that followed us wherever we went we've
made mainly stayed on the universe a lot
I think I can't remember where but he
had all his workout equipment in there
and at lunch time I would go I said you
know I'm gonna work out with you
it's hysterical and you know he's a
giant like animal you know he's like big
and he's got you know legs like this and
arms like that and he had a life cycle
in the thing and I I said let's do that
I'll do that while you do he did a
circuit of lifting on pumping and and I
did the life cycle at level four
you know 15 minutes and he did the left
he did the life cycle at level 15.
for 20 minutes and it was like I could
not even get the thing to move I'd stand
on the pedal and push and couldn't get
it to move so then we'd go have lunch
and at lunch he knew I was trying to
lose weight I've been on a diet since I
was 10. he
ordered dessert
like one day I was sweating I was like
in there you know getting ready to
all of a sudden the woman walks in with
like ice cream cake cannolis the whole
thing he brings him in to give to me
it's like tempting me and of course
after I just did this workout I didn't
want to contaminate my body
so how many desserts did you have three
thank you
foreign
[Music]